la consolidado el triunfo no es sólo
boca de urna como lo han informado hay
un conteo rápido realizado por una
institución múltiple universidades en
fin sobre 4700 mesas y que van a haber
cambios sustantivos se trata
principalmente de un voto práctico el de
la población
bajo la influencia tanto de la epidemia
de coronavirus cuanto por las
consecuencias económicas que ha traído
de una gestión corrupta y abusiva del
gobierno tránsito y 20 vino de las
señoras agnès el votante decide que es
mejor lo malo conocido que lo peor por
conocer cuáles serán los principales
desafíos señor cortes para el nuevo
gobierno
sobre vivir más allá de la mitad de su
mandato global va a tener una gestión
destacada en los tres primeros meses
porque el keynesianismo del señor ar se
le permite captar las claves aceptadas
universalmente en este momento para
combatir situaciones de la índole que se
vive en todo el mundo a raíz de la
epidemia de coronavirus pero más
adelante agobiado por el peso de la
deuda que ha dejado de obras
multimillonarias sin ninguna utilidad y
de las cuales no ha reconocido la
responsabilidad de una profunda
corrupción va a tener problemas que
aunados a la ruptura del monolitismo
interno de él
del más van a estimular al señor morales
para que esté en la fila de quienes
quieran que este mandato del señor ar se
termine lo antes posible porque querrás
sustituirlo qué rol puede ocupar evo
morales en el eventual gobierno de luis
arce
va a ser un poder detrás del trono pero
arce ha sido claro va a tratar de
imprimir su propio sello
esto puede mantenerse durante un cierto
tiempo pero le digo le reitero que ante
la acumulación de problemas de crisis en
todos los ámbitos ambiental sanitario
económico social y político
evo empezar a impacientarse y pensar que
sólo él puede resolver los problemas de
suministro
baa con los cuales suministro va a
tropezar sin posibilidad real de
enfrentarlos porque su menú no es
apropiado la economía boliviana del
modelo vigente en bolivia está haciendo
agua por todas partes las grandes
fuentes de ingreso que le dieron solidez
por los super precios exportables están
todas en proceso de retroceso
las agresiones al medio ambiente para
satisfacer al sector agroindustrial
exportador con quemas masivas de voz es
vana a ahogar nuestro nuestro nuestra
recuperación económica la derecha
boliviana subestimó a evo morales y a su
partido el más cuáles fueron sus
principales errores
desde el primer día que morales ascendió
al gobierno lo subestimaron nunca
pensaron que podría ganar la elección en
2005 nunca pensaron que podría generar
un proyecto porque no entienden un país
que tiene una raíz y una presencia tan
profunda tan constante tan intensa de
población indígena cree esa derecha con
un criterio señorial completamente
obsoleto que se trata sólo de una
anécdota cuando esta impronta indígena
campesina está en la raíz y la
personalidad misma del país sin ella no
se entiende a bolivia
muy bien pues muchas gracias por esta
comunicación y por sus palabras roger
cortez él es docente analista e
investigador boliviano